I wanted to show you that I care okay
every day you show up here yeah with a
breakfast burrito right yeah and you you
face that thing before we start I try
yeah normally right up to the buzzer and
that can only result in what I imagine
is pretty bad
indigestion so I got you something
oh yeah bro let's [__] go yes right
there what is this that's a lifetime
supply for two weeks famotidine what is
it famo yeah don't read that
tidine family
second one I wanted to get you something
big something that made a statement
right you know turns out it was a little
smaller than what
I thought okay all right
[Applause]
you know what's really great about that
too I just uninstalled foreign
God damn it